welcome everybody to the seminar today
it's a pleasure to welcome marshall
burke who is an associate professor in
the department of earth systems science
at stanford university where he is also
the deputy director at the center on
food security and the environment
marshall's research uh focuses on social
and economic impacts of environmental
change and on measuring and
understanding economic livelihoods
across the developing world
i tend to think of marshall's work as
focusing on big questions using big data
using empirical methods that are very
carefully executed and one of the
interesting things about marshall's
research is that he publishes both in
economics and scientific journals and he
holds a phd in agricultural resource
economics from the university of
california
it's a pleasure to welcome here here
today he's going to be speaking to us on
understanding the causal impacts of
climate on human conflict and before i
turn it over to marshall to start his
seminar i'll just say that he welcomes
questions or interruptions
clarifications or comments throughout
the seminar you're welcome to just um
raise your hand feature and he'll either
see it and respond or i'll just give him
a little nudge to focus on your
questions and keep on with his
presentation so without any further
introduction welcome marshall and we
look forward to your presentation
great thanks a lot matt uh and thank
thank you guys for having me too bad
couldn't uh make it in person hopefully
sometime uh in the future but uh but
thanks a lot for coming on what i hear
is a very rainy blustery day in in new
hampshire uh so let me share some slides
yeah so as matt said this is a
very much work in progress and would
love to get your feedback and your
comments and questions at any point so
please do jump in and interrupt it might
be hard for me to see uh the hands up so
so please be aggressive and uh
and intervening i'll try to also leave
some time at the end
for additional questions and
conversation because i think there's a
lot of ways we could take this work um
so uh as matt said this is going uh to
be a talk and again really work in
progress where we are trying to take a
big picture look at the relationship
between changes in
climate broadly construed although today
i will focus mainly on temperature
changes which are perhaps the best
studied and best observed
and its potential impacts on different
types of conflict around the world and
i'll try to define these more precisely
in a moment
but we are going to be casting a wide
net both in terms of how we think about
climate and in terms of how we think
about conflict
and we are going to be using data as
much data we can as we can assemble
either on our own or from existing
published studies uh to try to
characterize uh whether there's an
overall relationship on average and how
that relationship might differ across
settings uh and then to use that
backward-looking evidence from recent
history to try to say something about
what the world might look like going
forward as the climate warms uh and his
economies hopefully continue to develop
so this is joint work uh with two
berkeley collaborators ted mcgowan uh
sal shang uh three joel ferguson um so
ted and taller uh faculty there joel
ferguson is a great graduate student in
the ara department and jerryman is a uh
ra who works
with me here stanford
okay
so if i can advance my slides um
i think i'm speaking to a crowd that
thinks a lot about conflict and its
consequences so maybe uh
what my motivation here will be a little
bit preaching to the choir um but a lot
of people don't think a lot about
conflict but they do read stephen
pinker's uh popular press books these
are very popular and i'm sure many of
you have read
this very nice book better angels of our
nature subtitle why violence has
declined and in this book pinker really
takes a a very long view
century millennial scale view on on
human violence uh and argues
i would say you know fairly persuasively
that that over the very long run we've
seen a pretty remarkable decline
uh in humans being nasty towards one
another uh violent outcomes um and
really what he can study well here is is
more individual level conflict uh you
know uh homicide basically a lot of his
evidence comes from from homicide but
also has relevance for broader group
scale conflict so a lot of people read
this book and think well conflict is
sort of a thing of the past right yeah
maybe we still see somebody but it's
gone down substantially and we're much
more peaceful than we were
decades centuries millennia ago
um
that might be true but what is also true
is if you look at a more recent era we
have seen a
uh not monotonic you know not completely
steady but overall increase in various
types of conflict so
i apologize that the x-axis here is hard
to read the data here go from uh it's
the post-war period 1946 up to 2020 and
what you see in the different colors
here are the number of
conflicts around the world of various
types so these have sort of clinical
definitions and the in the darker blue
is what's officially called a civil war
that is a conflict in which a thousand
people died
and where one of the combatants is a
state
so think of this as a a state
either fighting another state or more
typically uh
fighting some other group some other
non-state actor within the country so
the wars are the very large one that
that kill over a thousand people uh and
the lighter colored reddish ones here
are minor ones that lead to at least 25
battle deaths often these are associated
with many more deaths beyond just a
battle dust but this is how these are
counted um and sort of no matter how you
count these the number uh you know sort
of peaked in the mid 90s after the um
end of cold war and then declined
afterwards stephen pinker wrote his book
but then in the last decade these have
come back up pretty dramatically and now
have reached totals that exceed what we
saw
during the really the most conflictual
post-war period which was the early 90s
in the world so now the annual number of
conflicts is at an all-time high post
world war ii
so
peaker might be right on the long view
but in the short review conflict is
certainly not going down if anything uh
it's going up uh they
you see conflicts around the world um so
this is not just concentrated in one
area here's the map from 2020 so these
are data from the ucdp for whatever
reason the scandinavians
have really committed themselves to
counting conflicts around the world so
all our great data come from different
groups in norway and sweden this is from
the ucdp and i'll show you various
analyses using the ucpp data here's just
a recent figure they put out showing
where these state-based conflicts are
happening
uh really right now so this is from last
year many of these are ongoing and as
you can see these are pretty widespread
uh around the world right they're not
just concentrated uh in one region so
conflicts going up
spread around the world uh we are in a
high conflict uh period right now and
again i think for this crew uh this this
stuff is well known uh but conflict
uh is bad on its own but it's also bad
because it it worsens many outcomes that
we care about so if you think about the
number of forced displacement uh
conflict is a leading cause of forced
displacement around the world and and no
surprise as conflicts have increased in
the last decade we've seen a steady
increase in the number of people either
internally displaced or crossing borders
to escape conflicts
again this is not just conflict driven
but conflict has been a large driver
here
you can also think of other outcomes
economic outcomes or food insecurity
outcomes so food insecurity uh or the
prevalence of under nutrition was on a
steady decline for many years again
until about a decade ago and now is
flattened down and if anything is on the
rise the last year here is is mainly
coveted related uh but a lot of this
flattening i think again can be
attributed to
the uh the increase in conflict right
it's it's reversing the progress that
we've seen uh against food insecurity
around the world okay so that's conflict
so why might climate be at all
irrelevant here uh let me motivate this
in a couple ways first by using some
quotes from
luminaries from the recent and distant
past so here's president barack obama um
when he
got elected and then immediately won the
nobel peace prize um
here's what he said during that speech
the world must come together to confront
climate change there is little
scientific dispute that if we do nothing
we will face more drought more famine
more mass displacement all of which will
fuel more conflict for decades so here
is uh obama over a decade ago making a
very strong empirical claim relating
changes in climate to conflict outcomes
uh we can go back further um
if i can advance my slide here we go
uh romeo and juliet so now we're going
back centuries um
if you remember romeo and juliet roughly
there's the good guys and the bad guys
here are the set of good guys
talking to each other benvolio and
mercutio these are good friends of romeo
um this is midway through roman juliet
so
they're on the street uh and it's a very
hot day so i pray the good mercutio
let's retire let's go inside the day is
hot the capulets the bad guys
abroad uh and if we meet we shall not
escape a brawl for now these hot days is
the mad blood stirring so basically uh
shakespeare is saying here there's just
something about it being hot that causes
us
uh to want to fight each other right uh
and sure enough they don't go inside um
all hell breaks loose many people die
right um and so
romeo and juliet and shakespeare in
general is typically not read as is
empirical work on climate and conflict
yet i would argue there's some early
evidence here in romeo and juliet
okay
so why might this actually matter so uh
if we go back to these um
quotes you can see obama i would say
making perhaps an economic argument
between changes in conditions economic
conditions livelihood conditions on the
ground and a propensity
for conflict so that's one potential
mechanism that might link climate and
conflict so if we think changes in
climate affect livelihoods and we think
changes in livelihoods affect the
propensity for conflict then uh you
could see a natural pathway from climate
to conflict
uh shakespeare is making a very
different argument right it's not about
economic conditions here it's just
something about the physiological
response uh to heat uh and i i think if
we introspect a little bit um and you
just think about how you feel on a hot
day potentially grumpier
um you might think cannot lead uh to
to changes in in certain types of
conflict outcomes just a physiological
response and i'll show you some evidence
that that actually that might be the
case
uh so there are multiple mechanisms so
again the obama story is perhaps about
economic conditions the shakespearean
story is perhaps about sort of
physiological or psychological response
uh there are other stories and and again
i'll get to the literature in a second
that has looked at this one is more a
migration story so maybe relevant to the
research of
folks at the macmillan center here um so
climate change can drive migration
there's good uh empirical evidence of
that uh and there are many studies
suggesting that
um migrants in various ways as they come
into new areas can
perhaps uh precipitate
conflict with uh you know people in the
in the receiving
location
another story uh long-term stories about
grievances so perhaps changes in climate
can uh amplify or multiply existing
grievances between groups as they alter
again economic conditions uh on the
ground so that's yet another story why
climate might matter for conflict
differentiating these stories is
something we're going to try to do in
this work and i'll get back to that
towards the end
okay
i want to emphasize from the very
beginning uh that that we are not
environmental determinists here nothing
we're going to study empirically links
between changes in climate and conflict
none of this should argue that climate
is the only nor the most important quote
unquote cause of conflict clearly there
are many other things that determine
whether or not a conflict happens uh we
are going to try to isolate the climate
component
uh of of these causes right so again
we're not being determinist here we're
just trying to understand empirically uh
is climate an important driver uh of of
observed conflict that we see okay uh
and so i i want to be very clear about
this um
but it could be an important and
basically this is an exercise to try to
understand how important it is uh
the defense department now talks about
climate as a threat multiplier so again
there are many existing threats you can
see sort of between the arrows here and
changes in climate might might alter or
or magnify those threats so policy
makers are using this language
and this could have specific
implications for interventions that we
might undertake right if climate is an
important cause that might change
actually what we do on the ground to
prevent future conflicts
uh from happening so that's why we're
going to study it okay so what do we
actually know about this so that it
turns out there's actually a very uh
large literature on this uh that's
really accelerated in the last decade so
um
with saul and ted uh almost a decade ago
now we did
what we thought of as the first sort of
empirical meta-analysis of the existing
literature back then there was a few
dozen studies
and here we're really focused on the
quantitative studies
studies that used
uh
longitudinal data for the most part to
study uh empirical relationships between
climate and conflict uh and so this was
published you know again in in 2013 and
and
we argued uh was the sort of best
empirical summary of of uh relationships
in the literature uh so here uh in this
study and in the update that i'm going
to show you we really focused on
settings where we could isolate the
impact of climate from all the other
potential causes of conflict right um
and so actually doing this in a
meta-analytic way requires going back to
the primary data in many of these
studies and re-analyzing them
in uh what we would think of as
statistically responsible ways and using
a statistical methodology that i'll talk
about in a second that again can really
isolate the impact of climate from all
the other things that could be
causing conflict
so the findings from this earlier
meta-analysis again in a few dozen
studies
we found that that increases in in
temperatures and in extreme
precipitation but again that the
temperature signal seemed the strongest
led to increases in both interpersonal
conflict think of this as as uh
violent assault or homicide and the
worst case outcome so so two people
having an incompatibility um and a
larger increase in inner group conflict
so think of this as the civil conflict
civil wars uh that i showed you before
um so robust statistically significant
um average relationships between climate
uh and and conflicts
uh
across the studies that exist so uh so
that was almost ten years ago now um
there has been an immense amount of work
on this in the last uh eight or ten
years since we published that um
so we want to revisit this earlier
analysis we want to understand whether
our earlier results still hold up given
the uh again the large amount that's
been published since um
i think what's been what's interesting
and what made us want to revisit this is
not only that but that that many new
types of conflict uh and violence around
the world are being studied um so i can
show you some results on that uh and
because we have a lot more literature
and a lot more data we have new
capabilities and
opportunities to understand the
mechanism linking climate and conflict
that was not something we could do a
very good job with um in the earlier
study and of course that's very
important if we want to think about
interventions
uh and finally again we've had a decade
with a lot more conflict uh and a decade
where we've seen lots of warming right
so you would think it's a decade where
we might be able to learn a lot
empirically about the relationship uh
between climate broadly uh and in
conflict
okay so here's what we're going to do in
this study um again
this is mainly a meta-analysis although
we are going to do some primary data
work as well so we are going to
update our earlier meta-analysis on uh
what we will call intergroup conflicts
so again think of these as groups
fighting groups this is civil conflicts
of a war
um
as well as some other outcomes i'll show
you in a moment um
so we're going to distinguish that from
interpersonal conflict these are
individuals uh potentially harming one
another homicide violent assault
um we are also going to add in the third
category of self-harm and so this is you
could think of instead of interpersonal
uh intra-personal conflict
there's been a lot of work on that
recently i'll show you that
number three we're going to dive deeper
into mechanism and i'll show you what
we've gotten done on that we're far from
having a full story here i'm going to
look at one potential mechanism that we
can observe and try to measure
and finally and i won't get to this
today we want to think about potential
climate impacts um
both in understanding what climate
scientists call attribution so what of
the existing the the the
changes that we've already observed in
conflict what can be attributed to
changes in climate
uh and second would be a projection a
forward-looking thing so what might we
think would happen in the future given
what we've observed uh in the recent
past as temperatures continue to warm so
i won't do either of those today i'll
sort of try to set that up but that part
of the analysis is uh
not complete
okay marshall marshall can i just jump
in with a quick question yeah please
maybe you're gonna yeah maybe you're
gonna get to this but one just thing i i
wonder and i thought about this with the
first slide that you had with the trend
in conflict over time
because over time to what extent does
like the data that we know about the
increased prevalence
of violence relate to just more
comprehensive and sophisticated ways of
collecting data yeah it's a great
question so one thing you would very
much be worried about is uh is time
trends for various reasons but one just
a reporting
uh
artifact basically we we have better
data on where and when conflicts occur
and so we record more of them over time
yeah that's absolutely right and i think
that is is definitely part of some of
these data sets so uh the way many of
these climate event data sets work is
they is they scrape basically news
reports
so they look at local news reports
either from media organizations from
humanitarian organizations
and then code these events as conflicts
or not using existing data that they can
find or estimate or put together on how
many people were affected right um
and it has to be the case that uh our
information from local news
organizations or from humanitarian
organizations has improved over time
leading to some of that trend
so we need to be very careful about that
exact problem and think about how to
control for the possibility that of an
overall secular increase just due
to reporting
and so in the analysis
that i'm going to show you what we can
do is try to control
either across all the data or in sort of
a local way for any sort of
secular what we would call time trends
right anything else that's driving
trends in conflict over time uh that
might not be climate and again reporting
is is one of the things we're going to
worry about yeah so you're exactly right
uh and and hopefully we're doing a good
job
trying to account for the the reporting
part of it
um okay so again uh this is a
quantitative analysis we are not going
to focus on a very large and important
case study literature thinking about
conflict we are going to focus
uh for better or worse on quantitative
studies that again statistically relate
changes in conflict outcomes to changes
in observed climate
and in particular
we are going to focus on studies that
can observe fixed populations over time
as the climate fluctuates so um
sort of a standard example here perhaps
so
you might think of let's let's compare
norway to nigeria right so norway is
historically been fairly peaceful at
least in the past half century go back
further less the case but uh
thinking in recent area
era norway is is fairly peaceful nigeria
has unfortunately experienced a lot of
conflict norway tends to be quite cool
nigeria is quite hot so a naive analysis
would say you get more conflict uh where
it's hot because nigeria has more
conflict than norway right
obviously that's not a great comparison
we might think that norway and nigeria
differ in all sorts of other ways other
than just their average temperature and
so that could be a very confounded
comparison so we do not uh include
studies that make those sorts of
cross-sectional comparisons instead we
want to use studies that
don't compare norway to nigeria but
compare nigeria or some other location
to itself over time as it experiences
hotter versus cooler uh or wetter versus
drier years right
um
so uh again we're going to use within
location variation over time uh
and controlling
uh you know as matt brought up for any
other thing that could be trending in a
common way across all units over time so
if we think this sort of reporting
effect is
sort of similar across a lot of
different units let's say all countries
in africa sort of saw an increase in
conflict just because
uh we're now reporting on more conflict
in africa we're going to sort of control
for that by accounting for an africa
wide trend or an africa wide a year
fixed effect in the in the parlance here
so uh the the sort of technology we're
going to be using here the statistical
technology is panel fixed effects
regression um i didn't put up any
equations here more than happy to go
into the details on this um
and it that the comparisons that come
out of these are basically the ones that
that are on the slide
um there are other things you want to do
in these regressions so we're actually
going to push the data pretty hard we
want to account for potential lagged
effects of temperature as well
those could go in two directions it
could be the case that multiple years of
negative climate exposure increases
conflict so you want to account for
both current and previous exposure it's
also the case that a hot year last year
could have caused a conflict to occur
that was already going to occur anyway
right and that's what we would think of
as displacement so if you think there's
potential displacement going on and this
has actually been
well studied in the in the heat and
mortality literature
you need to also include lags of your
climate variables again i didn't want to
go into too much detail on that but
happy to talk about the statistical
details there
in any case we're running panel fixed
regressions we call these distributed
lag regressions where we're including
multiple lags of our climate variables
and we're adding up the effects
across lags to generate the overall
effect
that that was the only uh statistical
sort of uh dive i had there again happy
to talk about that
okay so a quick rewind analysis and i'll
show you some actual results here what
can this inc and
what can't this tell you so it cannot
tell you
anything about specific conflicts all
right so this sort of statistical
approach and the meta-analysis we're
going to do on top of it cannot tell us
that climate caused the syrian conflict
right
uh it just can't what it can say instead
is do changing like
on average do changing climatic
conditions make conflict more likely
right and again typically not individual
conflicts it has little to say often
about individual conflicts because the
the counterfactual the unobserved uh
counterfactual for that conflict is
again unobserved
what it can say is uh in years that are
hotter or drier on average are you more
likely to see conflicts and does that
affect differ as a function of other
things we observe
um
so that's what we're going to be able to
do okay so again and
the reason for doing this is uh we think
at least threefold this might be able to
help us anticipate the future impacts of
climate change so there's an important
climate change question here and
thinking about the overall cost of
climate change or how much we should
mitigate climate change right if if
increased conflict is a consequence of a
warming climate then that's something we
should account for when we make policy
decisions about how much to mitigate
um it might help us understand the
underlying determinants of conflict
right um if we do see large increases
due to climatic changes that might help
us
hone our theories about why conflicts
happen and what to do about them
and again finally in in the what to do
about them since uh it might help us
identify interventions that have at
least average benefits it's not
necessarily benefits for specific
conflicts because again it's going to be
hard for us to say something
statistically responsible about specific
conflicts
okay
so here's our study sample um so again
we cast a broad uh net as possible
across many different domains so these
are papers from
economics political science
uh
geography criminology
uh anthropology
marketing science um so think of this as
a very cross-disciplinary look um this
is you know months and months of google
scholar searching and tracking down
citations of citations uh we include
working papers um as you'll see we we
often have to go back and re-analyze uh
these data so we have contacted dozens
and dozens of authors
requested their data
if they're willing to share it or or if
they're not ready to share it we've
requested them to run additional
analyses that we want to see run many
have cooperated
and so the studies that are included are
typically ones where we can either
access the data or get authors to
run the fixed effects specification that
we want them
to run
so across the different types of
conflicts we look at conflict outcomes
we look at right now we have 68 studies
in our sample this is
uh likely to grow over time
and most of these were published since
we did our last
analysis right so 70 of these
um
have shown up more recently here's the
sort of time trend of our our when
studies in our sample were published um
so a lot of activity on this in the last
five to ten years and and on the right
is i know we're not supposed to show pie
charts it's a sort of a dirty pleasure
of mine i get to show a pie chart um
this is the
geographic sample so it's really spread
out around the world so a lot of our
group level conflict is going to come
from afghan asia much more of our
individual level conflict observations
is going to come from
wealthier countries in the oecd
and we have multiple countries sort of
20 of our our data really take a global
look so that look at more than one
um
more than one
continent okay
pause there for a sec
hopefully the overall inclusion criteria
are clear so again this is going to
cause us to not look at um
at least in a in the meta-analysis sense
a lot of
important qualitative work thinking
about
the causes uh of conflict so this is
again a quantitative
metabolism uh okay so initial questions
we're going to try to answer what is the
average effect of climate and i'm saying
that in quotes i think about this is
warmer temperatures or more extreme
rainfall those are the two
main
types of climatic variation that we're
going to be able to look at so what is
the average effect of a change in in
climate for a
for a given type of conflict and again
we're going to use those three different
groups of conflict uh number two do
effects vary across settings um so you
might see point estimates in different
studies that look different
are those truly different or are the
differences attributable just to
sampling variability to statistical
noise right
so
if we want to say that studies are
different and finding different effects
we need to be able to differentiate
those two things true underlying
heterogeneity from sampling variability
i'll show you some bayesian techniques
we use to do that
and finally can we understand and
predict why effects vary
over settings
okay so again three different types of
conflicts i'm going to show you three
figures that look like this
uh each line here is a study uh the
print here is very small because we have
lots of different studies maybe not the
best way to show these data so each line
here is a study
the solid line is the point estimate of
the effect from that study the
relationship between climate and
conflict
you can see the zero line here sort of
roughly equivalent to the blue line
right so anything to the left says
warming temperatures or more extreme
rainfall is reducing the likelihood of
conflict anything to the right of it is
saying the opposite warming temperatures
increase conflict or more extreme
rainfall increases
conflict
um okay so this is intergroup conflict
and again we've cast a pretty wide net
and dumped a lot of things into this
intergroup bucket so we're looking at
civil wars we're looking at riots we're
looking at coups we're looking at
terrorist events we're looking at
communal so non-state-based conflict
and those are sort of listed along the
outcome
column here if you can see that and
finally again here are the locations so
these vary
from pretty small scale locations so
studies just looking at you know one
corner of sub-saharan africa or looking
at syria um to global level studies that
use country level or gridded level data
from around the world
okay so you see the point estimates
there and underlying the point estimates
are the confidence interval um
and so these are bootstrap confidence
intervals where each little
transparent line is a is a different
resample from that same study so to
we are interested in the statistical
uncertainty for each of these studies
and so we are going to basically
resample the data from each of these
studies and re-estimate that effect uh
many many times
and so studies where the confidence
intervals are narrow tend to be ones so
here's one if you can see my cursor
where you see a lot of mass right around
the point estimate many of these other
uncertain
studies especially the ones with very
large effect sizes turn out to be quite
uncertain right they have large point
estimates but the confidence intervals
on these studies are quite large
and again i will note that the estimates
shown here are often not the ones that
you would find in these studies
themselves we have re-analyzed these
data and often we come up with very
different answers than what was in the
published paper and that's because
we are running what we argue is the
quote-unquote correct statistical
analysis for uh studying
uh this relationship
so this includes some of our own earlier
studies
uh here's one of mine burke at all 2009
we had a very statistically significant
result in that paper that we published
we have gone back and re-analyzed it and
it is
much less statistically significant than
what we had published before right
i think um
so so we're updating our own work as
well
i kind of see like in a generic sense
that do your like
panel fix effects approach would be the
right way to do this with
an appropriate data set
but you said like just sort of like
putting that sort of um
filter on the previous study i mean
presumably judgments were made when they
analyzed the study maybe they didn't do
the best but to what extent are you kind
of like
modulating it for each study as opposed
to just kind of everyone has to fit into
your
approach
yes just because it's very different
from the way you normally think about a
meta-analysis
it is um so there are a lot of research
or degrees of freedom in terms of how
to
to code the conflict outcome how to code
the climate exposure
and so we are letting researchers retain
or each paper retain a lot of those
researcher choices about
how to code conflict what conflict to
look at
what climatic exposure to look at right
all we're doing is saying uh you need to
have longitudinal data so we've just
selected studies that have longitudinal
data and you need to plausibly account
for confounding variables right
and so we're going to do that using
some sort of panel fixed effects
analysis most of these studies are doing
some version of that already
so some of them actually did not need
much alteration uh often the only thing
we're adding is in adding these sort of
lag terms that account for displacement
or amplification right in some cases
those weaken the results in some cases
they actually strengthen the results um
so to answer your question matt we're
trying to strike a balance between like
preserving a lot of the choices the sort
of structural choices the authors made
about
what outcome to look at what exposure to
look at and we're just trying to use the
same uh meta-analysis uh the the same
statistical
sort of framework
so yeah
you're right that this is different uh
than some of the meta-analyses that you
see which just take results off the
shelf right they don't worry about
necessarily the statistical analysis
that generated the results uh to us
and especially in this having looked at
many many many of these studies
that is that is a mistake
because a lot of the variation
for the same data set you can get very
different results if given the sort of
statistical choices you make about how
to run the regression and so to us a
better way of doing this is to keep the
regression that we're running fixed
and then let authors make choices about
what outcomes to look at what exposures
to look at
great marshall you gotta mess a question
in the chat here too it says market
indices
e eg
djia
shanghai composite the de-40 in germany
are virtually global in scope to a large
degree markets
market activities um let me see my
screen here anticipate and reflect
issues concerned with climate
change conflict political risk and more
would their inclusion as factors in your
models potentially add interpretive
value to your results
uh yeah interesting question um
so a lot if you look at our samples here
a lot of our samples a lot of our data
on group level conflict comes from
[Music]
the afghan context some from the asian
context um
and at least my experience working in
sub-saharan africa is that a lot of
these sort of international financial
aggregates uh are
that their um
their relevance for some of these rural
african contexts is is potentially
limited um
so i i'm not sure that their inclusion
would
and so i guess another way of putting it
is uh and i'll show you in a moment we
have if if the if the idea or the
concern is that we need to account for
local level variation in let's say
economic conditions uh we have more
direct ways of doing that that we can
that we can exploit in some of these
settings um so we're going to try to do
exactly that i think as the
as the
comment suggested maybe some local data
on on economic conditions could
um
could tell us something about what's
going on here uh we're going to do
exactly that
thanks
okay um so clearly there's a lot of
spread and point estimates so one thing
we can do is just take sort of the
average and here we're going to take
precision weighted mean so what's the
mean effect across all these studies
we are going to weight
this is a weighted mean where studies
that are more precise get higher weight
this is sort of a standard approach in
meta-analysis
for precipitation for rainfall the
precision weighted mean is is dead on
zero
so so it looks like uh precipitation
sort of on average again on average has
no effect so we get some negative
estimates we see some positive estimates
the precision weighted mean
uh zero uh for temperature it's not zero
so uh we find a precision weighted
effect of about six so sorry here the
units are in to make these studies
comparable the other thing we have to do
is convert everything into similar units
the units we use are percentage change
in the conflict outcome
per standard deviation change in the
climatic exposure so
i think that maybe makes sense for
preset for temperature we don't tend to
think of temperature in terms of
standard deviations um
so uh
so there's that
but to make it comparable we sort of
need to use it so um
so our average temperature effect is six
percent increase in complex first
standard deviation
uh change in temperature so if you think
a really hot year is a two
or greater standard deviation increase
in temperature
that means on average a really hot year
is associated with uh you know 10 to 15
percent increase uh in conflict right
so to us that's uh that's a meaningful
effect that's a pretty large effect okay
again that's the average effect there's
a lot of variation uh let me come back
to that variation in a moment that's
intergroup conflict here's interpersonal
conflict um here the effects tend to be
much smaller but much more precisely
estimated a lot of our data here come
from
[Music]
uh wealthier countries uh where we can
put together pretty detailed data on on
interpersonal conflicts so this is often
violent crime murder assault
domestic violence things like that um
and at least in some settings these are
pretty well measured in official
administrative data right
so here we have about two dozen
studies about 20 studies i guess right
now 25 estimates from almost 20 studies
again effect sizes are smaller but
they're very precisely estimated most of
these appear driven again by temperature
which is the best studied relationship
so hotter temperatures increase the
likelihood of interpersonal conflict
it's about two percent per standard
deviation
so again a very hot year a very hot week
think of it as a two or three standard
deviation
event then you get a six percent
increase uh in these different types
of conflict right um so again
it's not doubling conflict but it's
leading to measurable increases in the
occurrence of these different types of
conflict
so results are actually fairly
consistent for interpersonal conflict
finally for self-harm and this is the
more recent part of the literature
so looking at the relationship between
uh climatic exposure um and in the worst
case suicide so multiple studies looking
at suicide including some work that
we've done in the us and mexico um
and here again we see results that that
look more or less like the interpersonal
results in terms of their averages so
one percent-ish increase in
incidence of various types of self-harm
uh or or negative mental health issues
uh
per standard deviation change
in temperature
okay and
again smaller number of studies here
some variation uh in the in the point
estimates but overall positive
relationships
okay
so
uh i'm gonna focus mainly on temperature
that's uh where the earlier study our
earlier meta-analysis in our studies
here showed a more consistent
relationship
it looks like the mean effects are
positive uh
meaningful in a livelihood or economic
sense
uh but there's a lot of variation right
and so
we first want to understand whether this
variation is is
representing true underlying differences
in the effect sizes across these
settings is it true heterogeneity or is
it just sampling variation right is it
just the fact that a lot of these
estimates are really noisy and that we
can't really say statistically that the
effects are different across settings
how do we think about that
um so again how do we separate true
heterogeneity from sampling variability
what we're going to do here is estimate
hierarchical models if folks are
familiar with this economists have just
gotten excited about
these in the last few years
so
my bias here is is someone trained as an
economist uh who reads a lot of econ
papers um a couple really nice papers
rachel meager
vault in the last couple years have
introduced these techniques to to
economists but they've really existed
for a long time in the statistics
literature don rubin uh andrew gellman
um
and and so we're going to follow
their cookbook on how to do these things
uh and basically the idea here is uh and
i'm gonna show you a couple of equations
here uh but it's useful for thinking
about and it's really a nice way to
think about effects in these um
in this or any other meta-analysis right
so
um imagine we have a bunch of different
studies
and each has an estimate of a treatment
effect you care about so here our
treatment effect is the impact of a
changing climate on a conflict outcome
right so each one has a has an estimate
tau k and hat here means it's an
estimate right k index of studies so we
have case studies 68 studies total
um
what we're going to say in these
hierarchical models is the effect that
we observe the tau k that we observe uh
that is drawn from a distribution
of some true effect something that we
don't observe right with some standard
error right so think about uh there's
there's the observed effect
uh and it is an estimate of what the
true effect is in that specific setting
right so i'm studying the impact of
climate on conflict in syria right
um
i have an estimate from a study and
that's actually a draw from a
distribution around a true unobserved
effect okay
okay so that's read study and then each
study's effect is drawn from a broader
distribution right of true effects
uh and that thing has mean tau and some
standard deviation right
um
okay so we have individual studies uh
with true effects that we don't observe
and these true effects are themselves
drawn from this broader distribution
right and so the idea here uh is you can
write these things down as normal
um
distributions uh and you can estimate a
model that from the data basically
learns
what the true overall average effect is
across the study and whether those
effects truly differ with this so the
sigma squared tau thing is the
underlying true variance
in the effects across the studies right
and so you can see the hierarchy right
so this is a two level sort of hierarchy
you have the individual level estimates
and then you have the sort of group
level uh means
okay and basically what this is going to
tell you when you estimate these things
is that if this variance is greater than
zero then there is true underlying
heterogeneity uh in your
uh effects right uh and
that's that if it's different than zero
there's true underlying heterogeneity if
it's zero then that means all the
effects
have the same mean and that all of the
variation that you see in the point
estimates is just driven by sampling
noise uh in the in the sort of first
stage in the
in the estimation of individual level
treatment effects um this has a nice
mapping to external validity so if folks
are used to thinking about external
validity you hear this in applied micro
talks all the time how does your result
in setting a
what relevance does it have to new
setting b that's an external validity
question um
again the variance tells you something
about that right if this variance is
close to zero then that means the true
underlying effect does not differ across
settings right and so your a study from
one setting has almost perfect external
validity for to a study from another
setting
if this thing is large if there's true
underlying heterogeneity then you would
be worried about external validity right
your
study estimate from one setting is not
going to be necessarily representative
of what you might expect to find in
another setting
this approach gives you a quantitative
way of thinking about exactly that
question okay
so if the model is right and again
you're writing these things down as
normal you got to take some stands on
sort of what the distributions look like
um
there are some nice things that come out
of it right um and again i think of this
as a way of sort of disciplining our
uh our understanding of whether these
effects are the same or different right
so this first thing is it can tell you
what proportion of the overall variation
and effect sizes across studies is just
due to sampling noise right
and that's basically going to compare
your estimate of the underlying variance
to the study specific standard errors
right so in settings in which uh these
standard errors are really large and the
underlying variance is really small then
you're going to say almost all the over
underlying variation is just coming from
sampling points right
versus the setting when your standard
errors are really tight right your
studies are estimated really precisely
uh but your model says the underlying
variation is large there you're going to
say look all the variation is coming
from true underlying heterogeneity
okay so the model allows you to estimate
that it also allows you for each study
to then update your estimate to get a
posterior estimate of what the actual
effect in that study is going to be
right
uh and
the your estimate your best estimate is
going to be some weighted average of the
thing you actually estimated so this is
burke 2009 right the thing we ran before
so it's a weighted average of that and
our estimate of what the overall average
is where the weights are proportional to
how much sampling noise is in my study
right so if my study was garbage and it
was just all sampling noise then we're
basically going to give my study zero
weight and we're going to say what
marshall should have found in that paper
is just the average
effect across studies right so again it
gives us a way to think about not only
across the sample where's our variation
coming from but for individual studies
what was the likely effect in that
individual study given all the other
studies that we observed in the data set
finally it gives you a best guess as to
what if you did a new study in a new
setting uh what is your what's your
estimate going to be in that newsletter
so it's a really nice
again way to discipline our thinking
about
where is variation in our effect sizes
coming from when we look at a lot of
different estimates
of the same thing
okay i want to talk about estimation
here point you to the gelman
um
long gelman chapter uh from
which we followed to estimate these uh
in the recent meager papers uh if you
like the econ literature on this which
are quite clear on this
uh okay
so we're going to estimate these
hierarchical models so uh i
sorry i switched
i switched the notation here um
different papers use different notations
uh so sorry
here now mu is now the mean i i totally
screwed this up mu is now the mean so
think of this as the mean effect across
studies tau is now the standard
deviation right so this is the true
underlying mean this is the true
underlying standard deviation
if tau is zero there is no difference in
true effects across studies if tau is
greater than zero there is a difference
right
okay so focus again on the inner group
our mean is close to what i showed you
before so five to six uh again this is
in percentage uh point changes per
standard deviation change in climate
exposure so a five percent increase in
intergroup conflict per
standard deviation increase in
temperature
um so that's the mean what i showed you
before
uh what we would estimate from the model
is this has substantial true underlying
heterogeneity right we can reject that
the standard deviation
is zero in fact it's quite large it's
almost as large as the mean right so
what this would suggest is there's a lot
of true differences across the studies
um
same thing for interpersonal and same
thing for self-harm uh
although at least for interpersonal the
underlying variation is smaller than the
mean right so there we saw sort of
tighter standard errors
and when you see tighter standard errors
um and the effect sizes are pretty close
together
um
yeah you can you can get sort of tighter
overall distributions here um so
substantial but across all these
substantial true underlying
heterogeneity um but at least for
intergroup conflict that suggests that
at least over half of the overall
variation in effect sizes that i showed
you is driven by sampling noise so the
this pooling estimate suggests that 60
of the differences uh are just sampling
noise right
um are just the really wide confidence
intervals that we had on each of those
studies right
less true for interpersonal and much
less true for self-harm so this suggests
that actually most of the underlying
variation is coming from true
heterogeneity and not just from sampling
very load
okay so what does this tell us this
tells us that
of those wide
variations and effect sizes i showed you
before uh they are unlikely completely
driven by sampling variation there
there's likely true underlying
heterogeneity and that is particularly
true for interpersonal and self-harm
it's also perhaps somewhat true for the
intergroup stuff
as you can see here maybe 40 percent of
the remaining variation is due to true
underlying differences
uh okay the last thing that this
technology can give you again is the
updated estimates for individual studies
so the black points were what i showed
you before for intergroup conflict
individual study level estimates the
underlying gray line underneath it is
the standard errors on those estimates
right the confidence intervals
the posterior estimator sort of updated
estimate would be in red uh so for this
vulcan and sergenti this first study
their point estimate was fairly negative
negative five percent uh our bayesian
model is going to tell us
actually the true estimate in that
setting is more likely two percent
so basically the hierarchical model is
going to be very skeptical here of
negative estimates
negative and particularly negative noisy
estimates it's less
skeptical of this one this has a tight
standard error right um but overall it's
very skeptical of noisy estimates and
it's going to be quite skeptical of
things that are either quite negative or
quite positive right and so
uh the the
the term in the literature for referring
to these are shrunken estimates often
it's pulling these estimates towards the
mean
and the amount it pulls them towards the
mean depends on uh basically how
uncertain the estimates are right so the
more uncertain you are the more you get
pulled towards me
so if this is right then this says uh
it's actually most of these settings
were very unlikely to see the very large
estimates you get in some of these
papers were very little unlikely to see
unlikely to see large estimates unlikely
to see
negative estimates at all so only a few
of these remain negative uh once we
update our priors
okay so
now just making sure we go to
for 20 more minutes
all right i think we i think we go to um
three 3 45
3 45 okay yeah marshall just a question
about this so i mean the sort of
shrunken i mean it's by construction
right
i mean it's always it's always going to
turn out that way
isn't it
so there will always be a little bit of
shrinking uh unless the standard errors
are literally zero
um
so that the the amount of shrinking is
is going to be a function of how
uncertain your estimates are so for
intergroup conflict we have a lot of
really noisy estimates and so you're
going to get a lot of shrinkage right um
for for interpersonal i don't have the
numbers up but there we have a lot of
really tight standard errors and so when
you have a tight standard error the
model actually pretty highly weights
your estimate relative to the mean
right but it's like as long as you're if
the standard errors in a study tend to
go up when your
coefficient estimate tends to be further
from zero it's always going to shrink it
like this
that's a question not a statement no no
no you're you're right but the first
part of your question
um doesn't necessarily have to be true
it's true under publication bias
publication by story right but there
shouldn't be a relationship necessarily
between the coefficient estimate and the
size of your standard error right
uh
there often is because there is
publication bias
um but
like that there
there doesn't need to be right um but
you're right in practice there's
basically always uh shrinking but the
shrinking really is a function of the
how noisy each individual estimate is
so here we see a lot of
uh study level shrinkage
can i jump in with a quick question yeah
please
uh
i don't want to get too deep in the
nitty-gritty here but something i didn't
understand is are you treating all of
these studies as if they're drawn sort
of iid from that normal distribution
are you taking into account that there
could be some dependence between studies
in the same regions or of the same you
know subclass of violence
yes that is a very good question uh not
weeds at all
yes right now we are assuming they are
independent which is incorrect um so you
can
you can
build in a covariance
between like we don't have a good way of
sort of estimating how independent they
are i think you're absolutely right that
the assumption of independence is wrong
um
what i think it will do would be to in
this setting lead to uh further
shrinkage basically
um
that so it's a little easier to
implement in the precision weighted mean
setting where we can sort of assign
easily assign a sort of covariance
between studies and then calculate the
the weighted mean
um
yeah so so you're right right now we are
assuming independence um and that's
likely not correct
um i i think the implication is it's
gonna it will shrink things more
uh but it's a yeah it's a great point
thank you
yeah no thank you it's hard
it's hard to figure out exactly how to
implement that because you have to take
you got to take a stand on what that go
race looks like and like what you know
do you do it based on number of sort of
shared observation like how do you know
how do you do it
um
yeah so open to ideas that folks have
ideas about that smart way to do that we
we've
we don't have any
uh okay
so
last bit can we uh so there is true
underlying heterogeneity let's say so
that just tells us studies are different
it doesn't tell us why they're different
necessarily
so can we understand why they're
different so can we explain or predict
this heterogeneity uh and you could
imagine we could look at this in
different ways right what i showed you
before is is
so far is the between study differences
right do we have these estimates from
different studies we're getting more and
more estimates we still don't have that
many right so again we have a few dozen
for these different types of outcomes
so you're not super well powered to
understand um
potentially many different sources of
heterogeneity but that's one way of
doing it the other way of doing it is
actually looking within studies right so
to the extent within different studies
we can observe
sources of heterogeneity moderators
[Music]
within studies you actually have might
have a lot more data to do that so
imagine
a lot of these studies are running
these longitudinal fixed effects
regressions at a grid cell level so you
have a grid cell by year and africa
might have tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of good cells you might
have us counties by year and have three
thousand counties right and so in those
settings you have often very rich data
on
uh moderators of interest and so
actually have a lot more data and a lot
more statistical power to understand
uh heterogeneity
so we're actually right so far going to
focus and what i'll show you today is is
is looking within studies these studies
where we observe
some of the moderators that we're
interested in and study whether the
effect of climate on conflict differs as
a function of those moderators um but we
hope to do both of these things um what
one is just sort of a harder
harder to figure out how to do it in a
in a statistically powered way
um
okay
so
and
so far i'm only going to focus on one
potential driver of heterogeneity and
because i'm an economist i'm forced to
focus on something about economic
conditions as a key moderator
so that's what we're going to do this is
of course an economist favorite
potential moderator here so why might
the effective climate on conflict differ
across settings
um
if you believe that economic conditions
are the thing that links climate to
conflict so you get worsening climatic
conditions these change economic
conditions on the grounds and these
induce individuals to start or join
conflicts so that that's the typical
story that you will often see in the
economics literature it's a story about
um
opportunity cost right so
uh
a worsening climate uh
reduces the opportunity cost of joining
a conflict you need to put food put put
in like normal words you need to put
food on the table your crops have failed
this might be the only way to do it
um these conflicts actually typically
start with a very small number of people
so this doesn't have to turn every
single farmer into a fighter it just
needs to turn a few dozen of them
into such a thing or have hundreds join
a conflict right so just you need a few
at the margin to make this decision
that's the argument
so again i think there's some reasonably
strong evidence of that this is one
plausible channel at least in the
economics literature
um
you've also seen it in an individual
level conflict so it could be the case
that tough economic conditions uh in a
city or a location could make individual
level conflict more likely uh when
there's you know again some sort of
downturn or some sort of triggering
event brought on
um
by the uh you know by the climate or by
something else right um
i would say overall that this sort of
hypothesis is consistent with the
conventional wisdom you often see in the
climate impacts literature this is that
uh there's something uh insulating about
wealth right wealthier populations are
somehow less affected by changes in
climate and this is a i would say
there's a strong conventional wisdom
that you see
uh all the time i think people again
have different stories about why this
might be the case people can
afford to undertake protective behavior
they work in sectors that are just
fundamentally less affected by changes
in climate anyway
but again you see various flavors of
this all the time so all of these would
predict overall that you see a basic
heterogeneity
as a function of economic conditions on
the ground right so in wealthier
locations you should see less
relationship between climate
and conflict and on some level i think
we already know this to be true right we
have not seen
thank goodness uh civil conflicts or
civil wars in most most wealthy
countries in centuries right so if i
were to estimate the relationship
between climate and civil conflict in
most wealthy countries i would get a
zero right because we do not observe
civil conflict in those countries right
so variation in climate which we have
seen has not induced conflict of that
sort right
so on some level this has to be true um
we are going to try to estimate on a
more local level where whether it's true
in settings that we care about
okay
hey marshall i i don't wanna i don't
wanna affect your flow here but i don't
know i haven't been able to see some of
the chats but you got a question in here
another question it says um this is from
see my laptop here is from thomas b and
he says the linearly vertical shape of
the posterior shows both lack of fit as
well as virtually constant estimates to
me this suggests revisiting the model
assumptions eg the distribution of
normal area errors a different
distributional assumption e.g the weibo
or the couching might be worth testing
yeah i think that's fair uh yeah that
there's some def there's some there are
some choices you can make in in the in
the model and cauchy um
so the way you
yeah
you have to you have to make assumptions
or choices about what sort of
distributions you assume about the heirs
and and yeah i think you're right that
that normal might not be the best choice
here um yeah it's a great point
i i'm not sure that what i showed is is
necessarily indicative of poor fit
uh i think what it's indicative of is
given those assumptions that uh
and given the large statistical noise
large confidence intervals we've seen a
lot of these studies like we shouldn't
be surprised that a lot of those get
pulled in towards the mean right just
because they're highly uncertain um but
i think you're right that we should
explore
uh whether those results change if we if
we change our assumptions about the
underlying distribution i think that's
totally right
thanks
okay um
so
we're going to do this in three
different settings right now we're
working on expanding this right now this
is actually some primary data analysis
so uh to make sure we can do this in a
consistent way we've gone back and
and
re-analyzed uh gridded data across
sub-saharan africa over the last three
decades this is again those data from
ucdp that i showed you before so this is
gridded level civil conflict data um
the grid size here is like a 50
kilometer grid so these are
geo-referenced uh conflict event data
um
so we're going to look at that as our
group level conflict outcome and we're
going to look at homicide and violent
crime in the u.s as our individual level
outcomes
and again we're going to try to estimate
whether the effect size is the marginal
effect so the additional effect of an
increase in climate on a conflict
outcome either civil conflict or violent
crime in the u.s whether that differs as
a function of local level income which
we observe in the u.s our local level
asset wealth which is the sort of
economic
uh characteristic that we observe
in sub-saharan africa so the county
income level uh did
county level income data is just admin
data in the us
in a place like sub-saharan africa we
often don't have comprehensive data on
these outcomes so the data we are going
to use comes from a whole different set
of projects that i work on which is a
remote sensing machine learning based
approach to estimating local level
livelihoods
around the world including in
sub-saharan africa happy to talk more
about this we have a bunch of papers on
this uh here's one that we're going to
use directly
from last year led by some great
students
so and basically here we're going to
take existing level data on economic
characteristics on the ground this could
be local level asset wealth so think of
asset wealth as a summary index of the
assets that you own
tvs cars radios cell phones your roof
type what your house is made of whether
you have electricity right we basically
create an index out of that um
you're gonna have to talk more about
that that that index uh tends to be
pretty robust to what you throw in it
ownership of assets is tends to be
highly correlated um
and so we have some surveys where we
observe that and then we're gonna train
a model to actually predict that from
various sources of daytime and nighttime
satellite image right
and what we show in this paper and in
other papers that that does a lot better
than some of the things you see
in the econ literature pretty
prominently just using nighttime lights
imagery so there's a lot of issues with
nighttime lights and it turns out using
that in combination with daytime
multi-spectral satellite imagery lets
you do a a very good job of predicting
variation in
uh in asset wealth um so here i'm
showing you a figure from this paper
this is nigeria uh we've done this now
for all of sub-saharan africa back to
about 2003 so we have annual estimates
of very local level asset wealth across
sub-saharan africa for the last two
decades and so that's going to be our
sort of economic uh measure
that we're going to use as a source of
potential heterogeneity in sub-saharan
africa so again happy to talk more about
this uh data set but that's what we're
going to be using
okay so here's the three different
heterogeneity analyses uh i am looking
good on time uh this is last uh
empirical slide
um
so uh we see strong so so this is just
run as a linear interaction what i'm
showing you here we can do this
non-linearly
and it gets a little bit noisier but the
overall sort of slope is the same uh
basically at low levels of income uh we
can be quite confident that the
relationship uh is large and positive
for civil conflict in sub-saharan africa
so this is low levels of asset well for
a homicide in the u.s and for violent
crime uh in the u.s so uh i have
bootstrapped this regression a bunch of
times each line here is a different
bootstrap so this is i think i ran a
thousand times for each of these um so
it gives you sort of a sense of the
visual uncertainty the dark line if you
can see it as the overall sort of median
estimate uh across those bootstraps
so the estimates at higher wealth index
at higher income levels tend to be not
statistically significant
so again strong positive effects at low
parts of the asset or income
distribution
and then affects the decline towards
zero at higher incomes or higher levels
of asset wealth across both individual
individual level conflicts so again
homicide violent crime uh in civil
conflict
uh in africa so this is not a
meta-analysis of existing studies this
is now we're using data that have been
used in those studies and we're doing
this
ourselves
okay this is consistent with some great
country level work so there's a couple
studies out there a very nice study by t
rat and colleagues in mexico
by pima fetzer in india
that that leveraged various policy
experiments to show that
uh as in the indian case
uh workfare the enrega program was
rolled out across india this broke the
link between climate and conflict so
sort of a direct test of the income
hypothesis here similarly progressa in
in mexico uh villages or
localities that got progressa saw less
conflict uh as temperatures increase
so think of these results as consistent
with a few other uh existing very nice
quasi-experimental papers in the
literature right
so it looks like we do see strong
heterogeneity by income now i think we
should be a little cautious about these
results because income could be
correlated with other things that are
driving this heterogeneity right so we
are not going to have perfect designs to
be able to isolate the impact of income
from other things correlated with income
uh teavrat and demo and colleagues uh
you know that their designs i think are
going to be a little bit nicer than
these sort of cross-sectional
interactions we have here uh but again
overall it's consistent uh with with
what the literature seems to be saying
here
okay
um let me just finish up quickly uh so
implications for future conflict um so
hopefully i've convinced you that
looking backwards
at least in some settings we see pretty
substantial relationships between
warming in particular in various types
of conflict
but that this effect might differ as a
function of economic conditions average
economic conditions on the ground
and so effects seem to be amplified in
lower income lower wealth communities
either in sub-saharan africa or
in the u.s
okay so what do we have coming down the
pike so we have a lot of warming as
folks might know
we remade the sort of standard how much
is the world going to warm up map in
terms of standard deviations because
that's how we've done the analysis
and especially in the tropics so this is
the projected temperature increase by
2050 and standard deviations
this is the plot we made a few years ago
it's probably a little bit high right
now
uh temperature projections have come
down a little bit thank goodness um
but basically what you see in the
tropics is uh
better the tropics are from the tropics
you know the temperature just doesn't
vary that much right the year-to-year
variation is quite small and so a degree
or two increase in temperature is a huge
increase in terms of standard deviations
right it could be
up to a four
standard deviation increase in
temperature given historical variability
that's just really tight in the tropics
right so in terms of standard deviations
we expect massive increases uh across
the tropics uh in much lower increases
in the much higher latitudes where the
year-to-year variability historically
has been quite large right
so even though you're going to see more
warming in the higher latitudes in terms
of standard deviations it's actually
smaller
okay
uh
so if you believe the recent past can be
a guide for the future this would
suggest we have a lot of warming coming
down the pipe uh warming is rapidly
going to put uh push
societies in the tropics beyond what
they've experienced historically right
and so we might think that could
exacerbate conflict risk
but pushing back the other way is is
perhaps what i just showed you right if
there is income heterogeneity right if
we think that
rising incomes could help break the link
between climate and conflict uh if
development continues in the future as
it has in the recent past then maybe
that's a force pushing the other way
right you have warming pushing in one
direction and you have development
pushing in another direction so here's a
map i just made quickly of the african
asset wealth data we have this is now
aggregated to admin 2 level
but this is basically the growth in
asset wealth over time is estimated from
satellites and a lot of places are
growing really fast right you have many
parts of east africa parts of west
africa that are growing at
you know 0.2 standard deviations per
decade right which is really impressive
growth right so these places are
developing quickly and and our estimates
would suggest that that's going to again
reduce the likelihood that a negative
climate event triggers a conflict
outcome
okay so as these two forces sort of
pushing against each other uh as we go
forward here our goal is to try to say
something quantitative about those two
forces uh and and what the overall
effects might look like in the future um
that's not ready uh for public
consumption yet today so i'll just
i'll leave you with these maps so let me
wrap up here
again i would say fairly consistent
evidence that higher temperatures can
contribute not always but can contribute
to constant risk
again this seems uh we see this across
many different geographic settings many
different types of conflicts
and i would say the overall strength of
this evidence has grown a little bit
since the last study
our average effects are maybe a bit
smaller but we have a lot more evidence
saying that
they are that they are there
i think these effect sizes are
meaningful so a five to ten percent
increase or five percent increase per
standard deviation is large especially
if you think that
future climate change is going to lead
to a mini standard deviation increase in
temperature exposure rate so a naive
multiplication of those two things would
suggest large increases in conflict
um but again pushing the other way is
economic development right um and so to
me this is at least somewhat comforting
the fact that
economic development and the various
things that that brings can help break
the link between climate and conflict we
see some evidence that that's the case
um
so really it's going to be sort of a
horse race unfortunately between a
warming climate um and
hopefully developing economies um
and with i would say a sort of unknown
net impact uh that that we're gonna try
to estimate
so i will stop there uh thanks a lot for
your comments have a couple more minutes
and uh happy to hear more comments or
questions and and appreciate
the attendance thanks
well thanks marshall anybody who has any
comments or questions feel free to just
unmute yourself and jump in
good question marshall if you don't mind
yeah
um i was wondering if you could
do some of those those plots of these
study effect sizes um as like scatter
plots with either precision or the power
of the study on the y-axis
um it might be interesting to see
if there's like a discontinuity near
zero that would suggest
you know that there's some file drawer
problem or selection but publication
bias in which studies are actually
being put out there
yeah thanks that's a that's a great uh
idea i think it would be a nice way to
just look at the effects overall but as
as a sort of
one way of thinking about publication
bias uh i mean what's funny is like
often the
um
i think that's especially a useful way
of thinking about the existing estimates
that are in the published studies like
we think studies might be selected on
those estimates
often our re-analysis leads to estimates
that are quite different than what's in
the published paper so uh i would i
think there would be less
uh chance for publication bias and sort
of re estimates just because of the fact
that those were not often the published
estimates um
but
i think you're right that there's there
are a bunch of approaches for thinking
about
publication bias and the importance of
publication bias or the existing and
publication bias and these meta-analyses
and
and yeah and so we we need to do more of
that
yeah thanks
anybody else
well thanks marshall very interesting um
we've got you know uh i think the room
here that the weather here has probably
scared people from the room i see but
you guys
many uh interested folks online and
obviously an important and interesting
topic and so
i thank you on behalf of all the others
for an interesting seminar we look
forward to the future results that you
have coming down the line
all right thanks matt thanks for having
me thanks everybody for coming
take care bye-bye everybody take care
bye